انظري كيف كيف هذا الزوج اذا اخذنا الصوره
كيف يبكي وكيفها هو ايقن يعلم ان ان
اولاده في الاسفل ليك انظري كيف هو يبكي
انا التقيته منذ نصف ساعه وسالته هو فقط
ياتي هذا البكاء هذه قصته هي حالته ديدانه
عائلته
يعني كما نتابع معكم فعلا
المشهد والصوره ابلغ تعبير حتى نحن
حتى نحن حتى نحن كادق من اعلاميه او حتى
عندك مشكله في التعاطي يعني تصيرين الى
نقطه بالبعد الاعلامي المهني خلص تسقطين
على الارض بهذه المشاهده هي اصعب مشاهدات
انسانيه على الاطلاق ما مر ابدا على
التاريخ البشريه ليكي كيف ابدا هو يقوم
ويقعد زوجته هي قربه ليوم الخامس هو فقط
انه انا اولادي خلص هم تحت وانا اجلس
بقربهم ادرك 100 يمكن ان خمسه ايام سبعه
ايام هو لا يستطيع ان يخرجهم ولكن خلاص هو
معلق بهم هذه القصه هي هنا هي في الشارع
الاسفل هي في الشارع الاخر هي عند الام هي
عند العمه بالامس كان انه كيف يخرجون
اطفالا صغارا ملفوفين بحرامات وعمتهم تذهب
وتقبل ايدي والدهم وهي تصرخ وتقول يا الله
يا الله على الهواء لا تستطيعين ان تكبني
لا تستطيعين ان تقفي انا تركت تلك
المشاهده لانتقل الى مشاهده اخرى
هذا هي اذا صح التعبير
احوال
لقيامه مصغره عصفت بهذه المدينه